hey I'm Mark Cuban and today we're going
to be talking about mogul support pocho
silver 365 weather business or sports
when building your team are you more
interested in getting someone who is an
expert or something or would you rather
have something with more potential
question of the day Olivier I want an
expert everybody's got potential
everybody I want someone who knows
something give me someone who knows
there's every time because then I can
turn it into something real the key to
being successful in achieving your
dreams no matter what they are it's
finding something you really really like
to do and being great at it when you're
great at something you get to write your
own ticket so I'm always gonna hire the
expert if you just have potential
chances are you're working for the
expert
thanks Olivier charissa Sechrist I have
to do an elevator pitch for a business
proposal I've never done this what's
your advice Carissa get on an elevator
pitch alie the great so I pay off the
house or save cash and an accuser the
real answer is depends on what your
mortgage rate is if your mortgage rate
is over five six percent what you should
do is refinance if you have enough cash
to just pay off the entire mortgage
that's great but in this particular case
you probably want to talk to an
accountant because depending on what
state you live in there's all kinds of
different laws and rules for deductions
and so it can kind of get complicated
and as much as I'd like to give you
advice
talk to your accountants the best advice
Robert Reid ii as a hashtag entrepreneur
you get to be your own boss how do you
manage your time between work and home
so how do I manage my work-life balance
now it's easy I'm rich I do whatever I
want if I want to play with my kids I
play with my kids if I travel I jump on
my plane it really depends on where you
are in your life when I was first
getting started I was living six guys in
a 3-bedroom apartment and so I had no
work at home valence I was working at
night as a bartender and all I did was
work
I went seven years without a vacation
dude that's what it's going to take
that's home life balance trip though
doom if you're really into providing the
opportunity for people to grow their
network why they hate for crypto I CEO
is the new IPO here's the thing about
crypto particularly Bitcoin bitcoin is
worth what somebody will pay for it do
you ever see someone who collected
baseball cards and they were really
really really proud of their baseball
cards because they kept on saying they
were going to go up in price comic books
the same thing even artwork there's no
real intrinsic value you can't eat a
baseball card or shouldn't need a
baseball card your artwork might look
good on the wall but not much you can do
with it Bitcoin there's even less you
can do with it at least I can look at my
baseball card and go oh that's my
favorite player that's Roberto Clemente
I can look at art working on crypto is a
key that is so complicated for 99% of
the population do you put it in a device
do you print it out how do you keep from
being hacked
who's gonna host it for you it's just so
difficult that it's only worth what
somebody will pay for it so I say it's
like gold go to religion now people who
are really into gold they'll tell you
that there's a bad depression and things
go to hell in a handbasket if you own
gold and you'll be okay
no you won't you carry around a gold bar
so I was gonna hit your ass knock you
out and steal your gold bar and it's
gonna happen again and again and again
I'd rather have bananas I can eat
bananas crypto not so much look I can
make a great argument for blockchain
there's a lot of applications and
they'll be used but you don't need
public Bitcoin BTC you can create
blockchain on your own without using all
the available cryptocurrencies it's not
that I'm against crypto currencies you
just have to be very careful at best
their store value thanks coins or die
emcee sound studio what makes a good
business partner a good business partner
with somebody who makes me money at the
SNC k-pax the robots by the hour
WTF question mark so that tweet wasn't
replied to this one you are getting the
short end with tariffs if we as the
country invest in robotics we can build
factories anywhere including our own
that's how you replace cheap global
labor I'd rather pay you to monitor and
fix robots and tax the robots by the
hour
that's how you win so it just so happens
I have a company called higher robotics
and what does higher robotics do they
have robots that they put on factory
floors how do they charge the
manufacturer to put those robots on the
floor they charge them by the hour and
they charge them effectively what a
traditional labourer would cost except
they work 24 hours a day they don't have
to go to the bathroom they don't eat
they don't call in sick but the real
context of this tweet was how are we
going to compete with China Vietnam and
other countries who are manufacturing
things that have moved from the United
States to those countries and move jobs
with them so if as part of our
infrastructure spending with
public-private partnerships we invest in
robotics we'll be able to bring jobs
back here and replace the factories that
are in Asian countries in particular
with factories here that will allow us
particularly if we tax them by the hour
to be able to support social programs
that we may not be able to afford based
off what our politicians are saying it's
okay to tax a robot by the hour because
that money may come in and depending on
who wins the election it may pay for
health care may pay for single-payer it
may pay for ubi
it may pay for a lot of different things
but I'd much rather tax a robot who's
pulling in factory jobs from overseas
than any other option that I can see out
there at Larsen Jay tell me again why
there's no ABC shark tank for nonprofits
we're also businesses that need
investment for growth impact with a
return that's priceless invest in what
you value I'm going to tell you why we
don't have shark tank for nonprofits or
for kids it seems so sweet and so nice
but the minute we say no to a non-profit
we are their worst human beings on the
planet we can't do nonprofits we can't
do kids because we can't say yes to
everybody and so it's just better that
we don't do it at all from Chris winners
wince neither I'm CUBAN when you look
for leadership in your organization
what's the biggest success factor any
specific advice for engineering
leadership well I look for leadership I
look for a few things one it's somebody
who
can relate to people someone who can
define a vision someone who is nice and
someone who recognizes that it truly
comes down to helping people achieve
their personal goals and aligning those
with the goals of the organization if
you can take the goals of your
organization whether it's your company
or somebody you work for and align them
with the interests of the people that
work for you you'll be a great leader
and you also have to recognize in this
day and age people aren't looking for
lifetime jobs at a company they want
jobs that will help them improve their
own skillset so they can find a better
place in life that they enjoy and if you
help people realize their personal goals
like that great things will happen for
you as a leader Sade Wagner right where
is the first place to look to find a
business mentor how do you know if you
can trust them
I'm not a big mentor guy I've always
been a believer that if you really want
to learn something and be great at
something you have to put in the time a
lot of people look for mentors as
shortcuts when in reality maybe they
helped you a little bit maybe they
helped you avoid some mistakes but when
you're just getting started out in
particular it's okay to make those
mistakes and more importantly you have
to make the commitment to put in the
time to learn what you need to learn to
be created something you're good at what
you want to be good at Stewart plan
being able to trust an organization's
brand people and products are all key
components of business success question
mark so if your customer service how do
you gain and retain your customer stress
have you ever been a customer you treat
other people like you wanted to be
treated as a customer it's really really
really simple you know you gain and
retain a customer's trust by helping
them achieve their goals if you're in a
business that is a service business make
their life easier no one wants to go to
a store and have to work at buying
something the most valuable assets
everybody has its time the one thing you
cannot buy is time the one thing you
cannot get back is time if you make
someone's life easier your customers
lives easier if you help them save time
you will develop a great relationship
with them and you will
your trust hi you win how do I start a
business from scratch with no money no
credit and no expert friends to help you
don't from cryptic that crypto unlocked
at M Cuban hey Mark I have a question I
think many people would like to hear
your answer with all the talks of the
recession coming what do you think will
help someone go into it for the first
time for example Millennials @mq it just
so happens I answered that tweet and I
have it right here
number one refinance your student loan
and any other debt you have the reality
is right now interest rates are at an
all-time low so it's a perfect time to
go out there and refinance your debt to
save as much as you possibly can even if
it means continuing to live like a
student the greatest opportunities come
when you are one of the few people with
cash
number three understand the economics of
the company you work for it and the
impact a slowdown would have on your job
if you work for a company and there's a
recession coming and you understand your
role within that company you can
anticipate whether or not a slowdown in
business is going to impact your job for
better or worse
number four live as much like you can as
a student because the ultimate rule is
to lower your bills
to lower your stress number five don't
listen to any experts about whether or
not a recession is coming or not nobody
knows they're all guessing and I guess
because it helps them get on TV or get
interviewed probably on a podcast coz
all economists love to podcast number
five a because there's always a five
eight we live in a global economy
whether we like it or not the butterfly
effect applies we don't know what
combination our big or little things
will make things better or make things
worse factory could close in Vietnam
that impacts something else and that
impacts the global economy
you just don't know number six do all
you can to be great at your job but you
have to be honest with yourself
employees with no self-awareness are
always the first ones to get fired
number seven be someone who reduces the
stress of people around you it's always
the people who think they're
irreplaceable who caused the most stress
for everybody because they create this
hurricane of hellishness
right reduce the stress of people around
you be honest with yourself about
whether you're a stress creator or a
stress reducer because in my experiences
I'll always fire someone who creates
stress and I'll always look to keep
people and give raises to people who
reduce stress from Jordan snow uga
Scotch do you believe all jobs should
pay a living wage are not some jobs
supposed to be steps towards careers a
great deal of wages are based on how
easily replaceable people are ie the
positive training employees flipping
burgers was never supposed to support a
family of four I truly believe that
there should be a minimum wage of $15 an
hour and I say that because a if all
companies have to pay the same minimum
wage then we all play by the same rules
but that's not even the most important
part when somebody's not able to pay for
themselves and/or their families they go
out and get government services you know
who pays for it you and for others
they're not even able to get the
government services they need so you
know what happens that's what we see
people living on the streets I don't
want that you know what else happens
that's when we see people have food
insecurity they can't feed themselves
they can't feed their kids and so when
we help people and we're compassionate
and we allow them to live their lives
with a living wage then not only do we
make the country safer but we put
everybody in a position where they're
not dependent on government decisions
and government resources and government
tax revenue part 2 when a company
doesn't pay a minimum wage and they have
employees that are receiving government
assistance that means we as taxpayers
including you Jordan snow subsidizes
that company that's wrong I literally
went through my companies and asked and
checked to see if any of our employees
were receiving government assistance in
terms of their wages I made sure that
none were in a situation where they
qualified it for government assistant
because their wages weren't high enough
I don't want taxpayers to be subsidizing
my business so let's just raise the
minimum wage to a living wage and
compete because that's what American is
all about capitalism entrepreneurship
with a little bit of compassion thrown
in and I think would be a far better
place to live a far better country to
live in
presidential candidate Andrew yang
someone should definitely run against
Trump in the Republican primary against
William Welch at Mt
question mark higher up side than most
it's not over till I say it's over
Andrew you just wait and see I'm Mark
Cuban and this has been mogul support I
hope you learned something about
business entrepreneurship and most
importantly making money and even more
importantly being nice